thank you
[Music]
so here's a dilemma that I think we've
touched on it a little bit before but
this is a kind of a better example I
don't know which side you can be on this
but it is very interesting I'll be on
the right side dude all right it's it's
called the African elephant debate all
right dude I'm out
does that have to do with poaching
because I'm out dude I think that's just
one documentary of the African elephants
we're following their lifestyle they
have babies it was so cute right and
then
um one got like separated from the herd
when they went to drink water yeah and
they were all going this way and this
guy was going this way
he is following them but he's just
straggling behind and then the
documentarian was like without his herd
he will probably die alone
you [__] face why don't you tell him to
go the other way you can see just help
him can't interfere with nature
dangle carrot for him you know so uh I
was so mad there's this guy his name is
Randy matsumi he's a professional hunter
in Africa oh and um he's talking about
how uh the innovation of organized
trophy hunting answered a lot of
problems for the residents in African
regions like because like the elephants
would come and eat their exact farms and
plants the way that we see elephants
over here we're not part of their
Villages or towns yeah we just see them
as save them right that's kind of like
of course American mind right we all
just want elephants to live and be fine
um I just want them for the tusks yeah I
hear it's real good real valuable that's
all I see I just see piano keys
yeah
they're chess pieces I'm a little bit
different oh Colleen you love chess
right yeah
so uh Randy he's kind of trying to point
out something that hurts his community
and it's the Western meddling with uh
the country's Affairs and he calls it
colonial style where they are trying to
force their values on the system there
we're there it's the American way yeah
where they're saying like no it's not a
good thing to hunt these animals but
prior to that they were just being
poached anyway and when you poach an
elephant what happens is you waste most
of the elephant and also you're shooting
it with guns that where most of the
shots aren't even fatal so some of these
elephants don't go down and they just
have bullets in them but then if you
keep eating my stuff my corn then I I
don't have I run out of corn yeah but
also the African people also use all of
the elephant when they have yeah oh
that's really good yeah so uh it's a lot
of meat what they do is they'll
commission certain guidelines among
people that can come and Hunt specific
numbers of elephants and specific
elephants themselves they're gonna watch
the living for a long time and go that
is at this age it's okay to take this
one out it's not like a baby elephant or
something and uh a lot of the time if an
elephant attacks a village or eats too
much like crops like you said they'll be
like okay this elephant is a nuisance we
need it's okay to take this one out and
when they do it the the hunter the
professional guy will take you along
let's say you're the guy that's uh yeah
you're the you're the cool guy from
America that wants to do a trophy hunt
he'll bring you along you get your shot
he's aiming to if you don't get a fatal
shot oh you will do it oh yeah so that
there's no suffering that's really good
well no one actually looks into the
Nuance of these things right they go why
are you killing Dumbo you [__] [__]
face [__] yeah and and also you also
think like I don't know what it is but
when you look at animals that we don't
have here we just assume they're
endangered some of these areas have 150
000 elephants whoa it's not like it's
not enough I think there's like 10 or
something but uh they're starting to do
these bands on trophy hunting from the
other countries so not in Africa but
like in the UK they're trying to say you
can't bring back the trophy hunt
you can't bring back all these like
symbols so it's making less people want
to go out there anyway because they
can't bring back the whole point is to
like bring back the thing and also
that's the thing that they don't use so
a lot of the time yeah it's an old law
from um ivory trade yeah from poaching
and endangered species and things like
that so there's a lot of that remnants
still around where people think like
um your if you buy anything Ivory
whether it's like whale elephant you're
contributing to the poaching Black
Market yeah and so there's a lot of
illegal [__] like that yeah you can if
you let's say you do a legal trophy on
let's say you do it from America you do
go through this paperwork where you can
bring all those items back and it's okay
but now okay but there's taboo social
stigma because people are uneducated
even people that hunt like deer or elk
in America people look down oh there's a
new thing where in the UK you can't even
do that
well people in the UK are just stupid so
they're probably trying to hunt with
knives or something
they want to discourage it entirely they
don't like the idea of somebody going to
Africa but then that's what he's trying
to say he's like if the more you do that
he's he's afraid and this is a kind of a
crazy hot take he's like if you don't
let these nations trophy hunt in Africa
then
those Hunters that are going to come are
going to be from less scrupulous Nations
do you know what that's kind of saying
yeah gonna be a bunch of pirates no he's
saying basically that they like the way
that westerners and
um people like English people or UK
people are going to come and do the
trophy hunt there's at least a level of
respect because they've been doing it so
long that there's an understanding of
what it is but if it becomes all China
or some [__] that's all those guys
aren't that's not the same idea like
they might just go out with machine guns
and go this is more easy the value
system of what what those things are
going to be used for is a lot different
and they kind of like what they have
going now like it's like the Avatar
thing
because they killed them to
to like uh and then they kill them fast
yeah yeah it is like that there's like a
I mean that's kind of like how um
so there's an invasive like species the
hog like in Texas yeah yeah it's all
over America they um anywhere the hog
was introduced they [__] up the natural
land and all that stuff and so it's
invasive species and it's hurting the
like ecological system but there's a lot
of animal rights activists that are
against killing any animal for whatever
reason right but
um yeah I mean like but then it's
hurting the other animals and the native
plants and the native things and then
what about that Randy matsumi's main
point was pretty [__] hardcore he
goes stop putting animals higher than
the African people that was my take on
environmentalism I actually think a lot
of groups are hella racist because they
value the animal more than the natives
in the local population because they
actually do get so much money in like it
is no secret that Africa is gonna have a
harder time just getting getting Revenue
in yeah right like it's they don't have
as much of the infrastructure as most
like First World countries might and if
they're developing something here where
money's actually coming in and their
lives are getting better and then that's
getting slowly cut off because of value
systems that are foreign to them
people with good how do you do it
there's like people with good intention
that's ruined a lot of things in Africa
for example like
like clothing donations right
they destroy whatever economy they had
left for local manufacturers of clothing
right because what they'll do is like
they just get because there's too much
they'll dump so much product
of shirts and pants and whatever
and then it would just all these people
were like well I don't have any use for
it anymore same with um they did this
with this church organization did this
with eggs
so they're like hearing about this
country that had
um you know not enough food or whatever
and then they're like well let's give
them eggs because eggs have protein
they're easy whatever so they just
collected all these eggs and [__]
shipped it over and it destroyed
whatever egg industry they had in this
country wow
and now they became dependent on
um handouts because it's like if for
let's say 10 years you're just getting a
steady flow of non-stop food yeah then
it's like well how are we gonna be
self-sustaining
and then all of a sudden let's say these
churches have a different initiative
because like we supplied them with a
million eggs
yay okay now let's do this to Cambodia
and then like they're like all of a
sudden they're like oh [__] where are we
gonna have eggs now they're they're
cutting us off
so it's like people don't think [__]
through and like how these things can
damage they probably have a good it
starts from a good place but they don't
research how it their actions can
actually hurt yeah
give a man a fish
he will be today
he's a man of fish
the the other man will be a little tired
laughs